Yukihilok
[music]
You know ah
me Buber Hurry up to Yukimura Sati No way, it's only one more smartphone, isn't it
?
Hey, I
'll show you the results of my image training up until today
Orochi,
I'm getting excited all at once.
I'm standing here Thank you for taking it seriously You have a lot of
anger I'm
sorry I don't know what to do It's not the time to talk
back
No
[music] It's
over yeah It
seems to
have been a good thing I'm singing more than Gori A
certain customer founded this place
Ah, the customer who judged thank you
Isn't that child a ridiculous delusion The
customer's request has a heavy weight and a light one
Sort things out in your head before you act